xinjiang has now become a sensitive
issue
for china's consumers western clothing
and sportswear companies
who've raised concerns over the use of
forced labor
in the province's cotton industry are
being punished
as shoppers respond to calls to boycott
some of the biggest brands in the world
we are boycotting them because of the
statements they've made if what they've
said is true then we are willing to
accept this situation
but that's not the case that's why we
boycott them
i think that at heart i'm quite a
patriotic young person
so at least for now i won't buy anything
from these brands
the us government says the boycott is
the result of a state-led social media
campaign
but it also coincides with a deepening
diplomatic row
between china and western countries over
human rights in xinjiang
on monday a government spokesman had a
taunting message
for brands like sweden's h m
i've also seen on the internet that no
one is going to h m stores now
so what are the results can you survive
in the chinese market
can you still make money from the
chinese you can't earn a penny
china's government has repeatedly
rejected accusations
that forced labor including tens of
thousands of ethnic uyghur muslims
is used in its cotton industry that
accounts for around 20 percent
of global production the united nations
wants to investigate
that as well as other well-documented
evidence of repression
we have asked for the human rights
commissioner to be able to have a visit
in china
without any limitations in the excess
this is being negotiated at the present
moment between the office
of the i commissioner and the chinese
authorities while human rights groups
remain skeptical
about the prospects for a meaningful
visit with unimpeded access in china
the un secretary general says for now he
remains hopeful
an agreement can be reached adrian brown
al jazeera hong kong